[Musique]
quand on est acteur et qu'on a rendez
vous avec son agent et bien souvent ton
agent il te parle d autres talents
on passe souvent tout un déjeuner à
discuter de ce que font les autres et
les autres ont toujours de meilleurs
projets que toi rageant peux te dire
très bien sûr toi un mec comme moi non
mais là louis est en train de tourner
avec chago bras nar tu connais ce
cinéaste hong kong est celui qui avait
fait plastique mac adam hall nouveau
bras nord est complètement dingue le
scénario et après à la fois très chaud
tu arrêtes ton âge 1 clis est super je
suis très content pour lui mais qu'est
ce que tu as reçu pour moi alors pour
toi on a reçu un très joli texte qui
s'appelle la saucisse et on rit mais on
rit on brille à moment-la à peu près tu
es là bas âge on trouve plus la sauce
6h12 chercheuse au cices
ça se passe à côté de fontainebleau
fasse un bordel c'est très bien ficelé y
en a qui manque une chose sur 20
crucke manu mais je te jure c'est entre
rain man et la 7ème compagnie
et ce qui est fort et je trouve que là
où ils ont fait très fort et que la
saucisse parle je pense qu'il faut pas
qu'on passe à côté et manu j'ai répondu
à mon âge en écoute moi bien
il est absolument hors de question que
je joue dans un truc qui s'appelle la
saucisse l'élu en plus par curiosité je
peux vous garantir qu'il ne sera jamais
dans la catégorie qui suit celle du
meilleur scénario original